hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Marie
haha got my neighbor with me today
there's gonna be a few trailers that you
guys are not gonna be able to watch me
watch a friend of mine came like an hour
away today to watch a few trailers of me
and she's this hot-ass Chinese chick I
found out that the mic stopped working
halfway through the video and we did
like a few more trailers and it would
just be weird if I rewatched some
trailers so that wouldn't heat the whole
purpose and Marie someone who whenever
she's on it's usually be being like come
on Marie
please I don't want to do this alone
right now
it's literally now when today Marie
doesn't like she has nothing to do with
the film business that's why I love
having her on she's just a real person
I'm Joe America Joe America
that's who Marie Osmond break easy sure
your left a little bit perfect now we're
in the perfect frame all right all right
cool you can see Joker sup buddy
did you America make any sense that you
did that like what people get that or
are you gonna cut it out later because
it's weird and confusing comment below
and tell me if you got the joke we're
gonna watch the trailers today trailers
TV spots for god ZOA that's right and
I've seen a lot of Godzilla trailers so
far have you seen any of them I've seen
a lot of you reacting to the TV spots
Marine tell me what TV spots are like a
commercial on television of the movie so
they're not a full theatrical trailer
when you do this long enough you pick up
on terminology this is some hardly well
best of luck to you real fast that girl
that came over named Lauren gah hot ass
actress hire damn she's so cute she has
a boyfriend though other than that I'm
pretty sure she would go for me hi my
charmer really hope she's watching
what's up Lauren hey girl hey
and this TV spot is called secret can't
let them see your beautiful face all
right okay here we go
Godzilla this phone we haven't watched
the trailer together forever no not
since not since you saw Sly Cooper
together have we seen a trailer is there
guarding so carefully Christ was not a
natural disaster it was a force of
nature
you saw him you see him I thought my
son's leg and I thought he saw us it was
like what I saw it was like this big
pillar thing that looked organic cuz it
was kind of like roundish I don't you
know my glasses are really [ __ ] up
well you only get one chance to watch
these TV spots it's not like we can
rewind it back Maria has the coolest
glasses in each other your glasses okay
look at that they have a pin dad so now
the second TV spot called courage it's
about Godzilla mustering up the strength
to finally overcome some obstacles he's
had a rough life you know everywhere he
wanted to be really food who fed he
could bid you all the other animals
picked on him at the zoo
King Kong King Kong did [ __ ] him up yeah
King Kong is it I mean buddy what he did
to Mario King Kong [ __ ] up Mario what
you mean Donkey Kong it was a joke oh
gosh yeah Murray in the comedy okay so
we're gonna watch the courage TV spot
now I realize not all of you have had
hands-on experience none of us have ever
faced a situation quite like this one
that's nothing we'll never be more
needed than it is today
how scary it's really scary
whoa-oh there's a good shopping yes a la
mesa - I've got so much children I mean
that's my thing isn't it getting chills
yeah you get so much - I get chills
that's what I noticed Marie pointed out
to me that I get children it was like
that was a purposeful catch phrase but
no it's a real thing making sense this
is raw [ __ ] man
the real [ __ ] deal yeah yeah that was
a good trailer [ __ ]
oh man that got me so excited I kind of
want to watch the next one oh there we
go
this one's called lies natural disaster
Franken hello
you're lying it was definitely a
freaking bedroom your lot yeah I know
doesn't it his whole performance look
like Walter White's continuing as a
scientist I was hoping I was gonna be
more Malcolm in the Middle
yeah that would have been a much more
interesting film good TV spots
thanks for the recommendations people
anyway yeah the Godzilla movies like
epic I mean you can't say much more what
do you think Murray
it looks epic I want to see where
they're going with the nuclear
explosions I think they tried killing
Godzilla back then but it failed it
wasn't like a new thing like [ __ ] it
let's just get rid of New York like
because this is so awful oh maybe cuz
yeah I was thinking why would people
think it's an earthquake
wouldn't they see the giant [ __ ]
monster destroying everything I think
the soldiers said at the beginning it
was an earthquake the people think it's
an earthquake
we just really dumb them how could they
think it's an earthquake like how big is
Godzilla really he's [ __ ] junket like
we would have been away like we've
experienced earthquakes these as tall as
like New York buildings anything guys
if you're new to the channel subscribe
please and I promise I'll make sure the
mic is working every time whenever you
get oh speaking of requests shout out
time that's what the videos become at
this point Adolfo Rico Robles assuming
you're some spanish-speaking descent I
you said that I forgot about you he'll
nobody I remember you now these all want
a little people
he's awesome shut up Bernie you come on
my channel you make me look bad what is
wrong with you shout out to you homie
love you
East sixty foot three four five I yeah
you know what the [ __ ] do you say in
shoutouts what's up only you got
watching movies too are you doing how
you doing yeah are you yeah just ask
general questions to the blue mario
tower mina tower or - something like
that you're new to the channel welcome
but a welcome how you doing good to meet
you a dumb son of a [ __ ] yo that's the
thing is you want to insulate your
subscribers up front
we add revenue now you make me look very
such an [ __ ]